This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's this photograph tacked on the wall here in the studio. It was taken in 1899. The photo shows three men all wearing bowler hats, two of them in bow ties. They're looking dead on into the camera with this casual look of conquest. Knees raised, hands-on hips, suspended suspended midair on the lifted arm of a giant dredgy machine, a machine used to force the natural environment to bend to the will of humans. Even if you don't know this image in particular, you've seen images like it, scenes of people standing around proudly looking good as they shape the earth.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在我们工作室的墙上，贴着这样一张照片。它拍摄于1899年。照片上有三个男人，都戴着圆顶硬礼帽，其中两人系着领结。他们直视着镜头，带着一种轻松的征服者的神情。膝盖微屈，双手叉腰，悬浮在半空中，悬挂在一台巨型疏浚机的吊臂上——这是一台用来强迫自然环境屈服于人类意志的机器。即使你对这张照片并不熟悉，你也一定见过类似的画面——人们自豪地站在四周，神情自信，仿佛他们正在塑造地球。
What fascinates me about the pictures from this time is that they speak to this moment when there was a real sense of awe and reverence for the marvels of civil engineering. Now I don't mean to over-emanticize this stuff. A lot of things we did for the sake of progress were ethically dubious if not outright horrible. There were mountains tunneled, hills flattened, swamped, strained. But the environmental impact not was standing. These feats of engineering weren't just amazing for their time, they're amazing for our time. The photo I'm talking about, the three guys in Bollard hats on the judging machine, is a scene from the reversal of the Chicago River. And the reason that photo is famous,
这些老照片最让我着迷的地方在于，它们记录下了那个时代人们对土木工程奇迹的由衷惊叹与崇拜。我当然不是想过度美化这些事情。我们为了进步而做的许多事情，即使算不上十恶不赦，在伦理上也颇具争议。我们凿山、平岗、抽干沼泽、改造河流。但其产生的环境影响却是不容忽视的。这些工程壮举不仅在当时令人惊叹，放在今天也同样让人叹为观止。我刚才提到的那张照片，三个戴着圆顶硬礼帽的人站在疏浚机上，拍摄的正是芝加哥河改道工程的一个场景。而这张照片之所以出名，
or at least famous enough for me to have seen it, is because the reversal of the Chicago River. And the reason that photo is famous, or at least famous enough for me to have seen it, is because the reversal of the Chicago River was an enormous engineering project that was successful. But you've got to figure, there were countless other photographs depicting similarly awe-inspiring feats of engineering prowess that we have never seen, because those feats never got finished. They were, you could say, failures. Today we have the story of one such failure which, before people finally gave up on it, probably also once included a moment of men posing on machinery. So actually I do have a photo we can start from, dated to 1892. Reporter Julia Barton grew up in Dallas, Texas, where our story takes place.
或者说至少出名到让我能看到它，是因为芝加哥河的改道工程是一个获得了成功的庞大工程项目。但你想想也知道，肯定还有无数其他照片记录了同样令人敬畏的工程壮举，而我们却从未见过，因为那些工程从未完工。你可以说，它们失败了。今天我们要讲述的就是这样一个失败的故事：在人们最终放弃它之前，它可能也曾有过男人们在机械前摆姿势拍照的时刻。所以实际上，我确实有一张可以作为起点照片，拍摄于1892年。记者茱莉亚·巴顿在德克萨斯州达拉斯长大，我们的故事就发生在那里。
These men, a few of them in Boulder hats, are standing on a wide flat boat with a winch on top of it. A chain and a hook dangle down from the winch and they're hauling up a tree stump. The boats in a narrow muddy river, and it's surrounded by huge piles of broken up trees and other debris floating in the water. The boats name, Snagboat Dallas of Dallas. Oh man, I love that name. Growing up in Dallas,
这些男人中有些戴着圆顶硬礼帽，正站在一艘宽阔平坦的船上，船头上安着一台绞车。一根铁链和一个铁钩从绞车上垂下来，他们正在往上拉起一块树桩。船行驶在一条狭窄浑浊的河流中，周围漂浮着大量破碎的树木和其他杂物。这艘船的名字叫“达拉斯号清障船（Snagboat Dallas of Dallas）”。天哪，我太喜欢这个名字了。我在达拉斯长大，
I never saw pictures of things like the Snagboat Dallas of Dallas. I never heard of the failed project that generations of Dallas people spent their lives pursuing. Even though it concerns an engineering project so massive that it was once compared to both the Panama Canal and the great pyramids of Giza. This is the story of the port of Dallas. If you know anything about Texas Geography, you probably at least know that Dallas is not
从未见过诸如“达拉斯号清障船”之类的照片。我也从未听说过这个让几代达拉斯人穷尽一生去追求的失败项目。尽管它涉及的工程规模如此宏大，以至于曾被拿来与巴拿马运河和吉萨大金字塔相提并论。这就是达拉斯港的故事。如果你对德克萨斯州的地理有所了解，你大概至少知道达拉斯并不
close to the ocean. At all, it's more than 300 miles to the Gulf of Mexico. That's like trying to build a port to the Pacific Ocean in Reno, Nevada, or a port to the Atlantic in eastern Tennessee. But unlike Reno or eastern Tennessee, Dallas is at least located on a river that flows to the ocean, the Trinity. In Dallas though, the Trinity is really low and very narrow. So narrow that there are stories of Dallas's first fairyboat on the Trinity turning itself sideways to act as a bridge from time to time. So the Trinity was not a great way to move
靠近海洋。一点也不近，它距离墨西哥湾有300多英里（约483公里）。这就好比试图在内华达州的里诺建造一个通往太平洋的港口，或者在田纳西州东部建造一个通往大西洋的港口。但与里诺或田纳西州东部不同的是，达拉斯至少位于一条流向海洋的河流——三一河（Trinity River）畔。不过在达拉斯，三一河的水量实在太小，河面也极其狭窄。窄到有这样的传说：达拉斯在三一河上的第一艘渡轮有时会横过身来，充当临时桥梁。因此，利用三一河来运送
people or farm crops to the sea. But neither was the alternative. In the early days of Dallas in the 1840s and 1850s, if your goods weren't getting moved on a boat, they were in the back of a wagon getting pulled by a team of oxen. Railroads came to Dallas in 1872, but railroad companies could and did raise their rates whenever they felt like it. Dallas leaders wanted river navigation to keep access to the outside world affordable. But in addition to being low and narrow, the Trinity River is incredibly long and winding. So even though Dallas is about 300 miles to the ocean as the crow flies, with all the
人员或农作物到海里并不是一个好办法。但替代方案同样好不到哪里去。在1940和1850年代达拉斯的早期，如果你的货物不是靠船运送的，那就只能装在由牛队拉着的货车车厢里。铁路于1872年才开通到达拉斯，但铁路公司随时都可以、也确实经常随心所欲地提高运费。达拉斯的领导层渴望通过内河航运来保持与外部世界的联络，并确保运费合理。然而，三一河除了水浅河窄之外，还异常漫长且弯曲。因此，尽管按照直线距离计算，达拉斯距离海洋大约300英里，但加上
Trinity's meandering, it's closer to 700 miles of river. The few boats that made it to Dallas from the Gulf took nearly a year doing it. One of them was the aforementioned Snag boat Dallas of Dallas, which cleared debris called snags out of the water to make the river navigable to steam ships. One of the first of those was the steam boat HA Harvey Jr. When the HA Harvey Jr. finally made it to Dallas in 1893, the city went nuts. There was a massive parade, the local paper printed its front page in red ink. It was a huge day and they declared Dallas had become a port city as a result of that. Even the city directories, like the 191 city directories,
三一河蜿蜒曲折的河道，水路实际长度接近700英里（约1126公里）。那些从墨西哥湾艰难驶抵达拉斯的少数船只，几乎花了一整年的时间。其中一艘就是前面提到的“达拉斯号清障船”，它负责清理水中的障碍物（被称为“障碍木”），以便让蒸汽船通航。其中最早的蒸汽船之一是“H.A.哈维小号（HA Harvey Jr.）”。当“H.A.哈维小号”终于在1893年抵达达拉斯时，整个城市都陷入了疯狂。这里举行了规模宏大的游行，当地报纸甚至用红墨水印刷了头版。这是一个伟大的日子，他们宣布达拉斯从此成为了一座港口城市。甚至连城市指南，比如1901年的城市指南，
it describes Dallas as a port city. That's Dallas historian Darwin Payne. And the dynamic he's describing here in the city directory is very important when it comes to Dallas. There's the actual version of events, and then there's this grossly optimistic version. And as I was researching this story, this kind of boostery salesman voice kept coming at me
都将达拉斯描述为一座港口城市。说话的是达拉斯历史学家达尔文·佩恩。他在城市指南中描述的这种动态，对于了解达拉斯至关重要。一方面是事件的实际版本，另一方面则是这种极度乐观的版本。正当我研究这个故事时，这种带有鼓动性的推销员口吻不断从
in different forms, telling me that something that was absolutely untrue? Absolutely was true. We had Dallas-born actor William Jackson Harper voice various clippings from the written record of the 130-year-old history of the Trinity Project. Here he is as the Dallas Times Herald in 1893 in Sistine. The navigation of the Trinity is not a possibility it is an accomplished fact. Yeah, the H.A. Harvey made it, but that's just one boat. For more boats to follow, the river would have to become easier to navigate.
各种渠道向我袭来，告诉我某些绝对虚假的事情，绝对是真实的。我们请来了出生于达拉斯的演员威廉·杰克逊·哈珀（William Jackson Harper），为三一河项目130年历史的书面记录中的各种剪报配音。现在听到的是他在1893年为《达拉斯时报先驱报》配音的内容：“三一河的通航不再是一种可能性，而是一个已经实现的现实。”是的，“H.A.哈维号”确实成功抵达了，但这只是一艘船。要想让更多的船只随之而来，河道必须变得更容易通航。
And remember, this is the era of getting s**t done. We gotta move the river? Fine, let's move the river. Dallas convinced Congress to survey the river and figure out where locks and dams could help make it navigable. The Army Corps of Engineers finished the first lock and dam in the early 1900s at a site 13 miles below Dallas. But eventually, Congress shelved the project.
记住，这可是一个大刀阔斧、雷厉风行的时代。我们必须改变河流？行，那就改变河流。达拉斯说服了国会，对河流进行了勘测，并弄清楚在哪里修建船闸和水坝可以帮助实现通航。陆军工程兵团于20世纪初在达拉斯下游13英里处的一个地点完成了第一座船闸和水坝的建设。但最终，国会搁置了这个项目。
The locks and dams had already been built, molded. The locks and dams along the river stood deserted, and moss covered, and just as it had done before the white man came to Texas and rested an empire from the wilderness, the Trinity River, muddy, unclean, and turtle infested, wound sluggishly between its banks and sullen victory. But then the port of Dallas caught a second wind. The Trinity may have been turtle infested, but it wasn't always sluggish. In 1908 the river flooded, and it made a mess of Dallas. It turned downtown Dallas into a peninsula surrounded by raging flood waters.
船闸和水坝已经建成并投入使用。河边的船闸和水坝荒废了，长满了苔藓，正如白人来到德克萨斯并从荒野中夺取一个帝国之前那样，三一河流淌在河岸之间，浑浊、肮脏、布满乌龟，懒洋洋地扭动着，带着一种阴郁的胜利感。但随后，达拉斯港迎来了第二春。三一河可能布满乌龟，但它并不总是那么懒洋洋的。1908年，河流泛滥，把达拉斯搞得一团糟。它把达拉斯市中心变成了一个被汹涌洪水包围的半岛。
It devastated the city, and as a result result of that Dallas hired George Kester to create what was known as the Kessler Plan. Kessler was a famous urban planner, European trained, but he'd spent part of his youth in Dallas. He created a vision for the city that included boulevards and parks, but the part that really excited Dallas leaders was how Kessler reimagined a meandering Trinity. He envisioned it, becoming a straight channel about a half mile west of its existing course through Dallas. Levy's would contain the new channel and open up miles of floodplain for development
这场灾难对城市造成了毁灭性的打击，因此达拉斯雇用了乔治·凯斯勒（George Kester）来制定后来被称为“凯斯勒计划（Kessler Plan）”的方案。凯斯勒是一位著名的城市规划师，受过欧洲正统培训，但他的部分青少年时期是在达拉斯度过的。他为这座城市勾勒了一个包含林荫大道和公园的愿景，但真正让达拉斯领导层兴奋不已的是凯斯勒如何重新构想一条蜿蜒的三一河。他设想将其变成一条笔直的河道，位于达拉斯现有河道以西约半英里处。堤防将容纳新的河道，并为开发开辟数英里宽的洪泛区，
right next to downtown. Basically, they move the river out of downtown. Even if you do know the geography of Dallas, it's hard to picture exactly what this means. The project was even bigger than you would think, because it involved changes in the road roadways going over the sewer systems and utility connections and a huge earth moving project, of course. It's a vise to say, this was the kind of enormous project where there'd be pictures of giant machines topped by men in Boller hats. Well, by now we're talking 1928, so Fedora's would have been more in style.
就在市中心旁边。基本上，他们把河流从市中心移开了。即使你了解达拉斯的地理，也很难准确想象这意味着什么。这个项目的规模比你想象的还要宏大，因为它涉及到跨越排污系统的道路改造、公用设施连接，当然还有一项巨大的土方工程。毫不夸张地说，这是一个规模宏大的项目，现场到处都是戴着圆顶硬礼帽的人站在巨型机器顶上的照片。好吧，到了这个时候已经是1928年了，所以费多拉帽（Fedora）可能会更流行一些。
And so, starting in 1928, the river-moving project was a go. The city of Dallas dug the Trinity a 26-mile straight-shot channel, with tall levees on either side of it a half mile apart, perfect for the commercial barges that had now replaced steamboats. And make no mistake, historical record shows that even though this massive project was on its face about flood control, Dallas leaders at the time saw this as the resurrection of the port of Dallas. So in 1930, you got another ceremony for the port of Dallas.
因此，从1928年开始，河流改道工程正式启动。达拉斯市为三一河开凿了一条26英里（约41.8公里）长的笔直河道，河道两侧修建了高高的堤防，相距半英里，非常适合当时已经取代了蒸汽船的商业驳船。毫无疑问，历史记录显示，尽管这个宏大项目表面上是为了防洪，但当时的达拉斯领导层将其视为达拉斯港的复活。因此，在1930年，达拉斯港迎来了又一次庆典。
A bottle containing the sweet, sweet waters of the Gulf of Mexico, the final destination of the Trinity River, was smashed over a dredging machine, as people cheered on. A local pastor gave the benediction. May these engineers envision see the coming millions, who, when our virgin acres are upturned to the smiles of God, and our fabulous resources developed, shall people this empire. They really liked to lay an on-thake in those days. And from there, the plan to build the port of Dallas was really underway. There was a general will
人们欢呼雀跃，将一瓶装着墨西哥湾（三一河的最终归宿）甘甜清澈河水的瓶子砸在了一台疏浚机上。当地的一位牧师进行了祈祷：“愿这些工程师们的远见看到未来的千百万人，当我们的处女地迎着上帝的微笑被翻开，我们神话般的资源得到开发时，他们将 populate 这个帝国。”那时候的人们真的很喜欢说宏大的场面话。从那时起，建设达拉斯港的计划真正拉开了帷幕。各方都有着共同的
for it, there was political clout behind it, and there was eventually money to fund it. The Army Corps of Engineers came up with a really big plan to change the whole course of the Trinity to allow boats up to Dallas. And even further upstream to Fort Worth. President John F. Kennedy, just a month before he was assassinated in Dallas, signed off on a huge $900 million spending package for the Trinity. And despite the PR nightmare that befelled Dallas after JFK's death, the river plan kept on moving forward.
意愿，背后有政治势力支持，最终还有资金来支持它。陆军工程兵团提出了一个宏大的计划，旨在改变三一河的整个流向，以便让船只能够直达达拉斯。甚至可以一直向上游延伸到沃斯堡。就在肯尼迪总统在达拉斯遇刺前的一个月，他签署了一项高达9亿美元的三一河专项资金预算案。尽管肯尼迪总统遇刺后达拉斯陷入了公关噩梦，但河流治理计划仍在继续推进。
After all, the new president Lyndon B. Johnson was a Texan, and he was in favor of the project. Here he is talking on the phone in 1968 with Fort Worth Congressman Jim Wright. be the major dronyism of the game. Well, I won't be done, I'll be sure to help. Help's the rest of us. Dallas was ready. In anticipation of the soon-to-be navigable Trinity River, new freeway bridges constructed over the river were built extra tall to allow seagulling vessels clearance underneath.
毕竟，新总统林登·B·约翰逊（Lyndon B. Johnson）是德克萨斯州人，他对这个项目持支持态度。这里播放的是他在1968年与沃斯堡国会议员吉姆·赖特（Jim Wright）的电话录音：“……将成为这场游戏的主要经济动因。”“好吧，这不会完成，我一定会帮忙。帮助我们其余的人。”达拉斯已经准备好了。为了迎接即将通航的三一河，跨越河流新建的高速公路桥梁特意建得格外高，以便给航行通过的船只留出足够的净空高度。
Most bridges are constructed 15 to 20 feet above existing terrain. While these two high-rise viaducts rise to well over 60 feet. One reason is, so they may handle the hook for and saw after barge traffic, the Trinity proponents claim will pour into the Dallas Fordworth area. It's been 130 years. That's about 115 years longer than it took to build the great pyramid of Giza. Dallas is finally becoming a port city. Think of what this means.
大多数桥梁建在现有地面上方15到20英尺（约4.6至6.1米）的高度。而这两座高架高架桥则升高到了60多英尺（约18.3米）以上。原因之一是，它们可以应对三一河支持者声称将涌入达拉斯-沃斯堡地区的驳船交通所带来的通行需求。130年过去了。这比建造吉萨大金字塔所花的时间还要长大约115年。达拉斯终于要成为一座港口城市了。想想这意味着什么。
Sailor's loose on shore leave. Riverboat gambling cruises. Heavy industry. Loading docks. Fishermen. Longshoremen. Stevedores. Romantic picnics on the levees.
上岸休假的船员。河轮赌博巡游。重工业。货运码头。渔民。码头工人。装卸工。堤防上的浪漫野餐。
But then the port of Dallas hit a snack, so to speak. It went out not with a bang, but with the wine of a jet turbine engine. The great irony is that while all of this was taking place in the early 1970s, Dallas and Fort Worth were building an international airport. Rob Tranchion is a film producer who made a documentary about the Trinity for Dallas' public TV station KERA. He says the massive DFW airport invigorated the new economy growing here. Dallas was deindustrializing. The city had moved from its reliance on agriculture and trade to technology, light manufacturing,
但随后，达拉斯港可以说是遇到了一个“障碍”。它并不是在轰轰烈烈中消亡，而是在喷气涡轮发动机的尖啸声中落幕。极具讽刺意味的是，正当这一切在20世纪70年代初发生时，达拉斯和沃斯堡正在合力建造一座国际机场。罗布·特朗雄（Rob Tranchion）是一位电影制片人，他为达拉斯公共电视台KERA制作了一部关于三一河的纪录片。他说，规模宏大的达拉斯-沃斯堡国际机场（DFW）为这里不断增长的新经济注入了活力。达拉斯正在经历去工业化。这座城市已经不再依赖农业和贸易，而是转向了技术、轻工业、
banking and insurance. Companies like Texas Instruments were on the rise. They didn't need barges to reach the outside world. They had an airport. In my considered judgment, the canalization of the river would probably make Dallas go the way of the other port cities with a polluted channel which Houston has, increase crime, and increase deterioration of the inner city.
银行和保险业。德州仪器（Texas Instruments）等公司正在崛起。他们不需要驳船来与外界沟通。他们有机场。“以我之见，河流的运河化可能会让达拉斯走上其他港口城市的道路，拥有休斯顿那样受污染的河道，增加犯罪，并加剧内城的荒废。”
That's Alan Steeleman, who ran for Congress in Dallas in 1972. He ran against the Trinity Canal. It likely would mean the location of Steele Meals and petrochemical plants and other forms of heavy industry, none of which I won't locate in Dallas. And he won. Soon after that, voters rejected a referendum to spend their tax dollars on the canal. So right when the dream of those men aboard the snag boat Dallas of Dallas was finally on the cusp of reality, the dream was dead.
说话的是艾伦·斯蒂尔曼（Alan Steeleman），他于1972年在达拉斯竞选国会议员。他的竞选纲领是反对三一运河。这很可能会导致钢铁厂、石化厂和其他形式的重工业落户，而这些都不是我想在达拉斯看到的。他赢了。不久之后，选民们投票否决了一项将纳税人的钱用于修建运河的全民公投。因此，就在“达拉斯号清障船”上那些男人的梦想终于触手可及的时候，这个梦想破灭了。
Dallas would not become a port city, which was really a shame, not because Dallas needed to be a port, but because they totally messed up the natural landscape of the city. Remember, that the port of Dallas project eventually included the Kessler Plan, which literally moved the river and channeled it into a man-made canal outside of town. The Trinity River used to meander through the center of Dallas. It's hard to second-guess the civil engineering needs of the time. I mean, the river did flood the city pretty regularly, but one can help but think that this could have been a nice riverfront for people to stroll
达拉斯将不会成为一座港口城市，这其实很遗憾，不是因为达拉斯真的需要成为一个港口，而是因为他们把城市的自然景观彻底搞砸了。请记住，达拉斯港项目最终包括了凯斯勒计划，该计划字面意义上改变了河流的流向，将其引导到了镇外一个人工开凿的运河中。三一河曾经蜿蜒流经达拉斯市中心。现在很难去对当时的土木工程需求妄加猜测。我的意思是，这条河确实会定期淹没城市，但人们不禁会想，这里本可以成为一条供人们散步的美丽滨水河畔，
along, a beloved piece of nature in the middle of the city. The port of Dallas not only failed, but it stole the natural riverfront from the people of Dallas. Like a lot of people of my generation growing up in the 70s and 80s, I didn't really know there was a river in Dallas at all. You can kind of see the Trinity River in the title sequence of the TV show Dallas, which launched in 1978, but the camera mostly lingers on the skyscrapers. In real life, you might catch a glimpse of the river for a split second if you look down from one of those high freeway bridges.
成为城市中心一块备受喜爱的自然绿地。达拉斯港不仅失败了，而且它从达拉斯人民手中剥夺了天然的河岸风光。就像70年代和80年代长大的许多同龄人一样，我甚至不知道达拉斯有一条河。你可以在1978年开播的电视剧《达拉斯》的片头曲中隐约看到三一河的身影，但镜头主要还是停留在摩天大楼上。在现实生活中，如果你从其中一座高速公路高架桥上往下看，或许能瞥见一眼河水。
More often, you'd smell the river. A lot of Dallas's untreated sewage got dumped there. In the 70s, there were, after a hard rain in Dallas, this thing they called the black rise would royal downstream and kill everything in its path. The toxic sledge wasn't the worst thing to turn up in the river. I'm talking about dead bodies. The Trinity River bottom was the place where you'd hide the evidence. It was sketchy and unlit.
更多的时候，你闻到的是河水的气味。达拉斯的大量未经处理的污水都被倾倒在那里。在20世纪70年代，达拉斯经历一场大雨之后，会有种被称为“黑色涨水（black rise）”的东西顺流而下，杀死沿途的一切生灵。有毒的淤泥还不是河里出现的最糟糕的东西。我说的是浮尸。三一河底是藏匿证据的地方。那里阴暗、荒凉、没有路灯。
It was so dark that if you flew into Dallas at night, you could pick out the floodway because it was completely invisible. This dark artery flowed through the heart of the city. You would never think of going there, never. But of course, Julia now had to go there. She got in a canoe. Let's call it the Snag canoe Dallas of Dallas. Do you see the Snag at 12 o'clock?
天黑得伸手不见五指，如果你在夜间飞抵达拉斯，你是可以通过洪水泄洪道完全隐形来辨认出它的位置的。这条黑色的动脉流经城市的中心。你绝不会想要去那里，绝对不会。但当然，茱莉亚现在不得不去那里。她坐进了一艘独木舟。我们不妨称它为“达拉斯号清障独木舟”。你看到12点钟方向那个障碍物了吗？
Are you going to go to the right or the left? The trendy river resumes its natural winding core south of downtown Dallas. It flows through a dense hardwood forest. This part of the river bottom was left alone for decades because the plan was to someday bulldoze all this into a big turning basin and loading area for barges. Now the Autobahn's Azani has built a center at the edge of the forest and it leads canoe and kayak rides for urban river explorers. This is not the suburbs, this is not the country, this is the city.
你是打算往右走还是往左走？三一河流经达拉斯市中心南部时，恢复了其自然蜿蜒的河道。它穿过一片茂密的硬木森林。这片河底区域几十年来一直未被开发，因为当时的计划是有一天把这里全部推平，变成一个供驳船使用的大型回水盆地和装卸区。如今，奥杜邦学会（Audubon Society）在森林边缘建立了一个中心，为城市河流探险者组织独木舟和皮划艇体验活动。这里不是郊区，也不是乡村，这里是城市。
Oh I'm going to be so sunburned. So you've got 26 mile of river diverted into a walled off artificial channel, plus another long stretch shielded by dense forest. Making that easily accessible for public use is the huge urban planning challenge that Dallas now has to contend with. The good news is that the people now realize that this man made and man neglected landscape is the river they have,
哦，我要被晒伤了。所以，你有26英里长的河流被分流到一个封闭的人工河道中，再加上另一段被茂密森林遮蔽的漫长河段。如何让这些区域方便公众使用，是达拉斯现在必须面对的巨大城市规划挑战。好消息是，人们现在意识到，这片由人工改造又遭人工遗弃的景观正是他们拥有的河流，
and that's better than pretending that they have no river at all. It's a strange place. It's not exactly comfortable, but not the nightmare of my childhood imagination, either. It's a landscape stuck in anticipation of something that never happened. In the course of history, there are plenty of undertakings just as unlikely as the board of Dallas. We just don't think of the reversal of the Chicago River, or say the Panama Canal as
总比假装他们根本没有河流要好。这是一个奇怪的地方。它算不上舒适，但也没有我童年想象中的那么噩梦般可怕。这是一处陷入对从未发生之事的期待中无法自拔的景观。在历史的进程中，有许多像达拉斯港这样看似不可能的宏大企图。我们只是不会把芝加哥河改道，或者说把巴拿马运河视为
fallies, or forget about them entirely because against all odds they succeeded. And they were crowned with much hat wearing and machine posing. But when an engineering endeavor fails, sometimes all we get are scars on the landscape. And if we're lucky, we get to try again, make something good out of it, like a park. Hopefully with a plaque. I'd like it if they put up a plaque. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Julia Barton,
荒唐的闹剧，也不会完全忘记它们，因为它们排除万难成功了。它们头戴无数礼帽，在机器前留下自豪的身影。但当一项工程努力遭遇失败时，有时我们得到的唯有大地上的一道道伤疤。而如果我们足够幸运，我们还能有机会重来，从中创造美好的事物，比如一座公园。最好能立块牌子。如果能立块牌子，我会很高兴的。“99%隐形”本周由茱莉亚·巴顿制作，
a Sam Greenspan, Katie Mingle, Avery, Truffleman, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio KALW in San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, an architecture firm in the beautiful downtown Port of Oakland. You can keep up with all the coming and goings of 99 of 99pi on Twitter, Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify. I said hi to every single person who said hi to me on Twitter. You thought I was kidding.
参与制作的还有萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，由位于美丽奥克兰市中心海滨的建筑事务所Arxine的办公室制作播出。你可以在推特、脸书、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上关注“99pi”的点点滴滴。我在推特上向每一个向我打招呼的人打了招呼。你们以为我在开玩笑。
I was not kidding. And you're always welcome at our place at 99pi.org. Radio to you. From PRX. Radio Topeo from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我没有开玩笑。并且，我们随时欢迎你光临我们在99pi.org的网站。节目由PRX为您播出。节目由PRX为您播出。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。